[Musique]
feel your life 19h05 nous sommes en
direct ce soir avec quelques jours de
retard pour tester un nouveau jeu une
des grosses sorties qui était attendue
depuis une dernière 3 il ya un an
ghost of tsushima nous sommes bien en
lever du jour on vous le voyez pour
tester et bien ce nouveau jeu qui est
sorti vendredi des studio sucker punch
alors les studio sucker punch et nous
avait sorti quelques classiques de la
glissance playstation avec par exemple
toute la trilogie sly cooper qui était
un jeu d'infiltration à orienter
jeunesse de l'autre côté on avait aussi
les in famous mais en tout cas des jeux
qui n'était pas attendu peut-être autant
que button sushis makis et bien
succèdent dans les exclu playstation à
de last of us apart chaud on va suivre
bien cela en direct ce soir on va tester
on est là pour le tester avec vous
n'hésitez pas à nous dire un petit peu
ce que vous souhaitez voir à nous poser
toutes vos questions nous sommes pour
cela avec le et wati vous êtes
journaliste est qu au figaro on vous
retrouve comme souvent pour tester des
vidéos pour aussi par les biens high
tech aussi les nouvelles sorties et
surtout les dernières sorties
technologique qu'on peut observer
notamment dans le jeu vidéo
et là vous nous permettez vient de
tester en direct un jeu qui quand même
ça s'annonce en tout cas très très beau
là on peut le voir avec cette plaine
recouverte d'une brume matinale
alors avant d'aller dans le dieu j'ai
envie de dire je vais vous salue et je
vous salut a tous bonjour miss cutting
achats lounès mots
steph coiffure ou encore ken jincent sur
twitch sur facebook sur youtube mais
également sur la page principale du
figaro on est sur quatre canaux ce soir
c'est un plaisir de pouvoir vous
proposer autant de couvertures pour bien
ce test n'hésitez pas à nous dire
d'ailleurs ce que vous en pensez comme
ça on vous en fera plus souvent des
tests ou des des retours vidéoludique
j'ai envie de dire on vous remercie
alors je vois déjà votre question steve
coiffure vous me demandez si on a testé
la mise à jour minecraft alors pour
rendre les textures en 4k alors non on
n'a pas j'ai pas entendu parler de cette
mise à jour
en tout cas le jeu là est ce que il est
en cas de chaos il est déjà très bon au
clos alors
bonne question s'il disponibles en cas
de cas mais en tout cas parce que moi ma
console la playstation 2 playstation 4
classique donc elle n'affiche pas le 4k
donc voilà c'est ce n'est pas une
playstation 4 pro c'est une playstation
4 classique donc ça vous permet de vous
rendre compte aussi à quoi ressemble le
jeu voilà quand on n'a pas la version
supérieure de 7 de cette console mais
ouais ce jeu est extrêmement beau c'est
alors enfin il est très beau mais il ya
des moments s'il peut être très moche
donc c'est en fait il ya des textures
qui sont pas qui ne sont pas forcément
toujours génial mais globalement il ya
des effets de lumière qui sont très beau
donc là bon voilà brut pas brumes
matinales
il ya des effets de soleil des effets de
pluie de particules qui sont
particulièrement réussis ce qui fait que
c'est un peu un plaisir de parcourir ce
monde
donc monde d'une île japonaise nommé
sushiman une véritable île qui existe
réellement et qui donc bien nous permet
d'être
d'être explorées pour ce jeu on est en
2007 1274 au xiiie siècle face à
l'invasion des mongols un jeu qui se
veut en tout cas réaliste sur le plan de
son contexte historique est ce que le
jeu se veut réaliste sur le reste sur
les combats sur les réelles et relations
avec les pnj comme ça se passe aubin il
faut pas non plus faut s'attendre à une
reconstruction reconstitution historique
extrêmement fidèle un nom c'est gosso
tsushima ça reste un bon gros
blockbuster un bon gros triple a dont la
formule vous la connaissez absolument
parker voilà si je vous montre la carte
du jeu vous avez vous dirais mais j'ai
déjà vu ça
donc vous voyez tout plein de petits
points à explorer avec des missions
principales par ici des missions
secondaires par là des camps a libéré
des villes libérées
des défaites quand des camps de
survivants qu'on découvre voilà des
petits pois interrogations genre où il
ya peut-être des choses allaient voir
là-bas ou aussi donc là ce sont des
sanctuaires en fait c'est un mécanisme
qui ressemblent beaucoup et ça s'est
inscrite en fait c'est des sanctuaires
qui sont à hauteur et il ya toute une
phase de plateforme a réalisé donc à de
la grimpette c'est extrêmement facile
c'est papa de la plateforme très
exigeante et une fois qu'on arrive et là
oh voilà on a une petite récompense
totalement cosmétique
je crois que ça permet d'avoir
je ne sais plus quoi mais genre un petit
bonus soit soit c'est un petit bonus au
niveau des statistiques ou soit juste
voilà c'est juste un magnifique
fourreaux pour votre sabre
donc voilà en fait voilà quand on voit
la carte donc là je suis sur la première
partie de l'île pour vous donner une
idée là sur cette sauvegarde je dois
avoir à peu près dix heures de jeu
maintenant donc je n'ai pas encore fini
de tout explorer et après il ya cette
deuxième partie de cartes et ensuite
cette troisième partie
donc voilà il ya quand même de quoi
faire surtout si vous décidez de bien de
bien tout exploré dans tous les sens
mais
donc ouais ça reste ça il faut bien le
dire parce qu'aux tsushima n'est pas le
jeu qui va révolutionner la playstation
c'est vrai que en tout cas dans les
différents traits leurs aidants les
attentes qu'on a eu surtout de par sa sa
date de sortie n'a été annoncée en même
temps que de last of us s'il sort
peut-être à une grosse semaine d'écart
avec de la sauce
on aurait pu s'attendre à un jeu assez
réaliste là si on regarde si on s'en
tient à ce qu'on voit actuellement à
l'écran vous aurez l'impression gagnent
que c'est un jeu réaliste alors moi j'ai
une première question en ce qui concerne
le game design vous aviez dit que ça on
a des séquences de d'escaladé dans ce
qu'on en voit là ça semble plutôt
réaliste on est sur une plaine moi par
exemple un des grosses critiques que
j'ai pu faire au dernier jeu star wars
the force unleashed
c'était que les phases de plates formes
et les légumes game design n'était pas
du tout naturel n'était pas du tout
réaliste et qu'au contraire on était
avec des gros grosses perches
il faut grimper ici faut aller là qu'est
ce que vous en pensez de ce jeu là
dessus elle alors excusez-moi j'ai je
suis serein sur un combat et j'ai été
des crous en très basse comparée vous
montrer les combats donc là c'est les
nos amis d
mongol alors attendre un petit peu
m'écarter parce qu'ils sont quand même
très très nombreux donc on va y aller
les uns après les autres
hop en tout cas en ce qui concerne le
design des personnages le jeu est plutôt
réussi un ca c'est beau on voit les
différences d'armes avec de culture pour
vraiment différente les continentaux
mongol le japonais avec son sobre c'est
soit un joli en tout cas et donc si je
comprends bien ce que vous m'avez
expliqué avant cet âge on a des
catégories d'ennemis c'est à dire des on
a des brutes on a des ennemis léger on a
des lances et selon les lancent chacun
chaque ennemi et bien il ya des types de
combats a abordé adopter pour pouvoir
bien ouais voilà c'est ce qu'ils
appellent les postures de
les postures de combat dont il y en a
plusieurs qui se débloquent au fur et à
mesure du jeu donc lâché sur la posture
de la pierre qui me permet de combattre
plus facilement les ennemis doté de
sabre encore la posture de l'odon classe
et ceux qui sont dotés de boucliers et
plus tard se débloque voilà pour les
lanciers et pour les brutes donc en fait
ceux des cds des gros monsieur avec des
dés très très gros bouclier qui vous
foncent dessus et qui sont pas très
sympas
voilà c'est pour vous donner pour vous
donner une idée est donc pour revenir à
la question précédente
ce qu'est ce que sur le game design
alors moi y'a un truc que j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup dans ce jeu
et que vous pouvez peut-être deviné en
regardant en regardant mon écran c'est
que healy a très très peu de choses
affichez dessus oui donc là bon il
considère que j'ai toujours en combat
mais bon comme les mecs qu'ils ont
disparu pop
on va dire que ça compte pas mais quand
vous explorez le jeu en fait il n'y a
rien sur votre écran il ya juste votre
environnement autour de vous et pour
vous allez dire mais comment est ce
qu'on fait pour se déplacer pour savoir
où aller pour savoir où est la prochaine
la prochaine mission en fait c'est très
simple vous choisissez vous voulez aller
sur la mappe up est en fait c'est le
vent qui va vous guider
donc à vous voyez des jolies petites
feuilles qui qui vous dise
et si jamais vous êtes un peu un peu
paumé vous êtes plus trop sûr de vous il
faut vous rendre vous appuyez donc sur
le pavé centrale le trackpad
non on a une solide il aura fallu une
génération de consoles pour une utilité
astres exposé bah écoute il vient de
faire à deux choses donc il sert au vent
donc vous avez une grosse bourrasque qui
vous dit part où aller
et aussi ah oui non là je peux pas mais
en fait on on peut on peut on peut jouer
de la flûte et dont ce qui permet de
faire apparaître le soleil donc si
jamais on n'a pas envie de combattre
sous la pluie un petit coup de flûte et
c'est parti c'est comme dans la vraie
vie
oui c'est cela c'est assez facile tu
veux d'abord les subventions bonjour à
tous et en tout cas merci de nous
rejoindre vous êtes nombreux et on vous
en remercie bonjour ta race et qui nous
dit ça me fait penser à la direction
artistique de cqi roba tout à faire
c'est quiero qui se passe également dans
un univers japonisant merci miss you
tiga chars je vais essayer de vous
saluer tous bonjour meije
[Musique]
merci steve coiffure qui qui nous
demande quand est ce que le jeu sort et
bien le jeu est sorti vendredi vous
pouvez y accéder
on avait aussi une question de maillage
qui nous demandait si on était en
partenaire avec le jeu banon peut laver
tout et on va aussi vous aborder les
défauts de ce jeu alors pour le moment
on vous en dit des choses bien mais ce
jeu n'est pas parfait bien évidemment ce
qu'on a aussi comme question chlorés
pour rebondir sur la question de steve
coiffure qui nous demande si on a des
peines des pertes de fps sur playstation
alors comment ça se passe en tout cas
sur les lélés les capacités du jeu bah
écoute moi je le trouve plutôt stable
j'ai pas vu vraiment de pertes non on
n'y a pas il ya pas vraiment de soucis
souci technique voilà ça ça rame pas ça
crache pas tout se passe plutôt bien
c'est c'est techniquement plutôt de
couteau souligner c'est rassurant parce
que moi j'ai eu la douloureuse
expérience il n'y a pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière de voir ma console
crashé à cause du jeu control way qui
qui n'a pas tenu et là on se rend compte
qu'on est qu'on arrive à une feinte de
génération donc c'est bien si les jeux
peuvent tourner son problème c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de
voyez pas de ralentissement pour moi
j'ai rien noté de ce genre là en dix
heures de jeu et je voulais revenir du
coup sur le fait que ça ressemblait
assez quiero alors oui dans l'univers
wii dans le design absolument pas dans
le gameplay fanal strictement rien à
voir loin dans à ce n'est pas aussi
réaliste aucun succès heroes ou voilà
c'est qui ressort jeu extrêmement
difficile
c'est un jeu dans laquelle il faut avoir
des réflexes en béton on se rapproche
plus d'un d'être saoul alors que là on
s'accroche plus d'un dans red dead
redemption ou d'en bas pour moi ça sera
ça ressemble beaucoup plus à un
assassin's creed dans la dans la manière
voilà dans lequel vous jouez les combats
les combats reste globalement assez
simple une fois que vous avez compris
comment il fonctionne même si des fois
ils peuvent être punitif on ne sait pas
trop pourquoi enfin au tout début
allez voir vous allez planter comme dans
du beurre dans les soldats mongols et
puis abandonné sa voiture annonça
devient un peu plus compliqué mais
mais voilà c'est ça reste du combat
arcade parle pas du tout dans ses
clients ne partait pas surtout pas dans
cette optique n'allait pas avoir des
combats aussi nerveux aussi aussi fou
que cette section d'accord dit non en
tout cas ce que vous en pensez si ce jeu
vous intéresse si vous avez prévu de la
voir si vous avez déjà acheté le jeu si
vous êtes dessus sans nous spolient bien
évidemment et surtout sans spoiler bien
tous nos internautes
mais dites nous ce que vous en pensez si
l inverse vous n'avez pas prévu de
prendre si je dis ça c'est notamment
parce que là on est quand même sur une
grosse sortie pour celui une sortie en
exclu après une énorme sortie celle de
the last of lost on est quand même sur
une sur anthony qui a eu par exemple je
sais pas l'exclure en open world du jeu
spider man qui va avoir son petit remake
avec miles morales qui devrait sortir
bientôt
sony qui quand même top des grands coups
en ce qui concerne les open world et ses
jeux la cua balago sushis mais en fait
c'est la dernière exclusivité de la
playstation 4
donc ces voix là ils marquent vraiment
une sorte de fin de génération ce que
maintenant évidemment tous les yeux sont
rivés sur la playstation 5 qui sortira
en fin d'année même si on ne sait pas
encore précisément quand mais bon vous
pouvez à mon avis parier sur novembre et
donc voilà et on arrive sur une fin de
cycle
gosso tsushima avait été annoncé si je
me souviens bien il ya deux ou deux ans
il y avait deux en deux ans halo 3 et
donc voilà il est pas aussi massives que
the last of us deux donc c'est sûr qu'il
pâtit un peu de la comparaison parce que
ben voilà on s'enquiert un peu moins de
personnes derrière il ya un peu moins de
budget il ya aussi un peu moins soutenue
au niveau au niveau marketing
mais voilà en tout cas sony a pu aligner
toutes ces exclusivités qui ont quand
même été extrêmement solide sur cette
génération enfin il ya aussi horizon 0
deurne
alors qui a été un très beau succès
des screenings aussi en son genre même
si c'est beaucoup moins bien vendus
parce que c'était quand même un concept
très particulier un peu perché auquel on
adhère ou on n'adhère pas mais quand
même qu'il ya une exclu d'un créateur
légendaire jeu vidéo et de l'avoir c'est
quand même pas mal
ar ce qui est par là ça va me parler de
vous montrer
dans le gameplay de gossau tsushima en
fait on peut jouer de deux manières donc
soit on y va à fond tellement la voie du
bushido
donc on
on va droit devant son ennemi et
et on le combat les yeux dans les yeux
d'accord vous êtes un excellent pardon
un excellent jeu de combat de samouraï
sur playstation 2 que je vous conseille
et sinon il ya une autre manière de
jouer qui est plutôt celle de la
furtivité de celle des petits maligne ou
qui vont plutôt mettre des coups de
sabre dans le dos donc le jeu vous dis
c'est pas très très bien en fait parce
que c'est pas ça être un samouraï s'est
passé pas très noble de faire ça mais il
ya quand même pas mal de missions qui
vous invite à être être plutôt furtive
si vous voulez que ça se passe plutôt
bien et en plus ça tombe bien parce que
les ennemis sur quand même globalement
assez stupide
donc voilà vous avez une touche magique
comme dans tous les jeux où il ya de
l'exploration il ya de la furtivité qui
vous permet de voir où sont vos amis
comment est ce qu'ils se déplacent voilà
donc voyez ce genre ah mais je penche
bien mon dos en avant et je te regarde
voilà genre à l'âge inspectent la
rivière on sait pas trop pourquoi on est
sûr de l'infiltration selon ses grands
chevaux quoi voilà bah cesser
l'infiltration puisque ou quoi
ouais c'est ça exactement up
oui mais bon toujours pas vu ah ben ça y
est ça commence à me voir et ce qui est
des modes de difficulté ou c'est un
hors-jeu en non il n'y a pas de mode de
difficulté d'accord en tout cas pendant
que
vous êtes trop pied des ennemis donc pas
dans la voie du bushido mais au couteau
on a des commentaires on vous en
remercie l'on re bonjour steve coiffure
vous me demandez si c'est un battle
royale et berlin pas du tout même si un
battle royale japonisant serait super
intéressant on à la question de miss
cutie gâcha qui nous a quittés qui
revient mais qui nous demandent si c'est
un rêve playboys tout à fait honnête se
plaît à l'ancienne on en fait aussi sur
le figaro et on vous les propose
régulièrement dès qu'il ya des grosses
sorties on essaye en tout cas de vous
les offrir même si on a raté de la
surface mais il faut dire qu'en ce
moment avec les contraintes sanitaires
c'est pas forcément facile oui en ce
moment là c'est pas évident de faire des
lacs parce que quand on est confiné chez
nous ce soit au niveau technique c'est
pas facile
le plus simple c'est tout je vous avoue
que de chez moi n'ayons pas la fine
bouche on va me permettre de stream et
plus mais dites-nous moi en tout cas
j'ai tout le matériel chez moi pour ce
crime et sur la playstation 4
donc n'hésitez pas si vous souhaitez
avoir plus de live comme ça sur le
figaro sur la figaro gaming oswald
n'hésitez pas et allez je me sacrifierai
pour la cause et j'essaierai de vous en
faire quelques uns
dites nous dans le chat comme ça moi je
pourrais utiliser vos commentaires pour
pour défendre la cause avec grand
plaisir
alors on a une question de président
benson sur twitch qui nous demande si on
peut faire des quêtes de manière
latérale et bien oui tout à fait
principal je vois très bien le
à quoi vous faites référence oui il ya
des quêtes
il ya des quêtes secondaires up
alors en ce qui concerne les phases de
combat est ce que on est plutôt sur un
assassin's creed ou sk mais sur ce qu'on
a pu voir très régulièrement sur un
format un petit peu arkham asylum un jeu
bagouet aussi leur calme mais avec avec
les électrons
[Musique]
voilà bon pardon excusez moi c'était un
petit peu laborieux en tout cas les
habitants donc voila voila abréger les
souffrances
c'est important mais en fait ça c'est
important c'est important
en fait vous avez vous avez peut-être vu
quand je jouais en fait en bas à gauche
de l'écran
il ya des petits cercles en fait c'est
la détermination détermination ça vous
permet de choses à régler par une vous
soigner parce que par la force de la
volonté vous que vous soyez tout seul et
ça permet aussi de lancer des sorts de
super attaque qui consomment pas votre
détermination ne faut pas non plus en
faire trop parce qu après qu un peu plus
soignée
et cette détermination se remplit au fur
et à mesure que vous combattez et aussi
si vous achever les ennemis ou quand
vous suivez en fertilité permis de
gagner en détermination et le nom total
de serpe des déterminations évoluent au
fur et à mesure du web à cette petite
non j'étais en train d'essayer de
répondre à votre question l'âge et les
caractéristiques du jeu c'est alors pour
répondre à votre question sur twitch de
maïs qui nous demandent s'il ya une
limite d'âge et bien oui c'était ce que
j'étais en train de regarder
c'est un jeu 18 ans et plus alors il n'y
a pas de démembrement à mon grand regret
un jusqu'à un jour samouraï sans
démembrements voilà c'est un peu triste
mais par contre c'est interdit aux moins
de 18 ans puisqu'il ya quand même pas
mal de sang on est quand même dans une
culture qu'on a vu notamment représenté
au cinéma qui est assez sanglante le
film de samouraï même le jeu de samouraï
est souvent assez assez violent est ce
que là on est quand même sur un côté
particulièrement violent où
contrairement à d'autres jeux ou écouter
de jeu c'est quand même assez c'est
assez violent bon la leçon vient
soudainement de partir de mon kimono
mais sinon j'en ai enfin voila il lui
saint-cloud
quand vous tuez et beaucoup tout début
quand vous croisez des n8 avec le choix
de faire une confrontation dont ça me
plaît peut-être vu en début de ronde et
but de live et donc en gros il vous êtes
l'un en face de l'autre et il faut
dégainer à temps pour banqueroute
le trancher en deux ans même si
techniquement il n'est pas découpé en
deux je sais que voilà mais non ça reste
c'est ma grosse déception serviront il
ya quand même du sang partout qui gicle
enfin c'est pas par jeu c'est un jeu
pour les enfants de 6 ans quoi ouais
ouais mais vous avez quand même la
possibilité dans les options d'affichage
voilà si ça vous gêne de retirer le sang
vous pouvez retirer le temps si ça on
peut retirer le sens et surtout il ya un
mode que vous m'avez fait découvrir tout
à l'heure qui m'a fait sauter de ma
chaise c'est génial un mode que rosa
cause kurosawa pardi qui donc est un mod
pour les amis cinéphiles si vous
connaissez pas vous avez très bon goût
si vous ne connaissez pas akira kurosawa
je vous conseille tous ses films dans
les années 80 notamment mais pas que
avec des films comme ran les sept
samouraïs kagemusha qui est excellent
également et qui est donc un petit peu
là la rolls des films de samouraïs avec
bien des représentations historiques qui
sont dignes de péplum
de la grande époque voilà on voulait
conseil est donc là c'est ce mode
hommage avec vous le voyez le petit
grain très traditionnelle qu'on peut
retrouver au cinéma dans noir et blanc
et qui donc bon là alors je pense pas
qu'on puisse faire l'ensemble de la
partie non non c'est pas super agréable
et ça moi et ils ont fait des choses qui
deviennent beaucoup moins visible dès
qu'on passe en noir et blanc mais voilà
bon ça permet d'avoir ce genre de jolies
et j'ai quand même un gardien qui est
quand même assez génial et c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal à il doit être pensé aux
samouraïs sent pas sans penser aux
oeuvres de kurosawa et d'autant qu'il ya
un mode photo absolument génial car go
slow sushi bâ est un jeu qui fait pour
faire des photos
tellement il est joli donc voilà d'une
pression de douche vous arrivez sur ce
mode à vous pouvez vous vouliez plein
d'options vous pouvez changer la vitesse
du vent vous pouvez dire ah j'ai envie
que ye ben toi je vous montrais
attendait jean vigne que apparaissent
hop genre des fleurs de cerisier
d'accord voilà où on en fait non un peu
de pollen a en fait non descendre des
braises parce que c'est la guérir ou des
lucioles
au début bellevue ou des papillons des
corbeaux oui c'est vrai alain qu'un mode
photo soit autant développé par contre
ce qui est intéressant c'est de
remarquer que désormais les jeux sont
tellement beaux qu'ils ont quasiment
tous leurs modes photo et on a un banc
d'un peu noir moi je m'en souviens de
mad max qui en avait un dans red dead
redemption comme vous nous le rappeler
steph coiffure vous en remercie bien
évidemment voilà dans beaucoup de jeux
c'est désormais naturel
on a des modes photo puisque bas il faut
dire que les jeux deviennent de plus en
plus beau et comme je disais avant cela
il me réjean ville et les jeunes
générations qui vont pouvoir prendre les
mains sur ces jeux est passé de red dead
redemption des jeux aussi beaux gosses
top socimat c'est quand même assez
impressionnant
alors que là on voit une ag aoussa tuer
une bête sauvage ah oui alors est-ce que
à la manière d'un witcher ou d'un red
dead redemption
il ya une relation avec la nature un peu
particulière allez quand même assez
assez light en la relation la nature là
en gros les seuls animaux vous pouvez
tuer fait en tout cas ça sert à quelque
chose de les tuer ce sont les ours ce
que ça vous permet d'avoir des de
récolter des pauvres qui vont vous
servir d'un peut-être pas de manière à
ce que je fais
voilà qui vous permet de faire du fer du
craft ouais non c'était vraiment pas une
bonne idée ça ça nous rappelle du cinéma
mais plutôt un film avec leonardo
dicaprio gretel tête ça finira mieux
pour les cépages suis pas sûr que oui
d'accord en est moins lisse club havrais
pas la peau de prédateurs par contre si
vous tuez des biches parce qu'il n'a
quand même pas mal qui passait bien ça
ne vous rapporte rien du tout et voilà
faut pas me tuer et à manger j'ai vu un
petit encart dans notre jeu utilisé
genre c'est très très mal vue de tuer
des biches d'accord donc donc voilà ne
le faites pas ça ne sert à rien si vous
voulez vraiment récupérer du matériel
pour le loot il faut il faut viser
plutôt les ours artois et je vais sortir
du mode course à voir voilà bah dites
nous en tout cas si vous avez des
références vidéoludiques ou des virus
des références cinématographiques qui
rappelle un peu le japon féodal
moi je vous en ai noté beaucoup puisque
j'aime beaucoup les jeux d'histoire et
les jeux et les films d'histoire on va
parler un petit peu aussi le japon
féodal mais pas que et on voit là avec
l'histoire qui peut être à la fois très
bien représenté dans le jeu vidéo et le
cinéma bien évidemment mais qui parfois
est un petit peu maltraité alors moi je
vous ai pris que deux très bonnes
références sur le japon on va pouvoir en
parler mais n'hésitez pas dans le chat
si vous avez des jeux ou des films qui
vous tiennent à coeur
ce sera avec grand plaisir est aussi a
fait montre un peu les menus donc en
fait vous avez différents types
d'équipements dont vous avez vraiment la
tenue l'armure de samouraï donc avec
comme vous pouvez voir réduit de tous
les dégâts de façon majeure augmentant
augmentation massive de la santé
apparemment la tenue pour aller au corps
à corps cette tenue la bourse a gelé
gagner via une quête annexe sait
vraiment si vous voulez être archer
voilà ça améliore tous vos statistiques
darche et la tenue de rona que j'adore
que je trouve très très belle
elle s'est plutôt sur la furtivité donc
il va jouer donc plutôt dégâts corps à
corps mais surtout furtivité on va
beaucoup moins vite vous détectez et la
tenue de voyageurs bon ça je lave ou le
titre quasiment pas en fait là c'est
plutôt pour des stats d'orientation run
je vois ça vous permet de découvrir plus
facilement un peu les secrets du monde
mais bon c'est une gestion des stocks
on peut retrouver dans des jeux comme
the witcher dans des sky rim par exemple
ou si on a trop d'objets on peut plus
marcher non non non puis au final en
fait eu assez peu de chose à ramasser
les autres chose à ramasser ces du
bambou du lin du cuir
et genre du fer de l'or mais ce genre de
matériau se gagne essentiellement via
l'émission ou en explorant les camps les
camps mongole est en fait c'est ce qui
permet d'améliorer d'améliorer tout son
matériel mail
et il ya aussi il faut récolter de
l'argent et je pense que les climat est
plutôt bien fait parce que c'est quand
même assez long de récolter tous et tous
ces matériaux donc vous n'allez pas non
plus devenir surpuissant très très vite
ouais parce que voilà c'est autant vous
allez avoir du bambou à ne plus savoir
qu'en faire autant va avoir pour avoir
le faire dont vous avez besoin pour
améliorer par exemple votre votre sabre
ça va être beaucoup plus lent donc voilà
donc il faut pouvoir vous aussi des
collectifs bulls qui servent à rien
voilà donc je connecte et des bannières
dont c'est pour obtenir une nouvelle
selle pour votre cheval rien des criques
et chantant voilà pour apprendre de
nouvelles mélodies à la flûte artefacts
mongols voilà c'est juste le côté
encyclopédies et ouais les objets tous
les ans on est vraiment dans un jeu au
traître un open world triple-a
extrêmement traditionnel
voilà donc j'ai plein de bambou de faux
63 morceau de bambou que je me traîne
depuis le début du jeu voilà des
marchandises provisions des fleurs dépôt
de prédateurs de la soie
voilà ça c'est pour le côté kraft et
quand vous allez dans
il faut aller dans certains camps par
exemple ici dans le temple d'or on va y
aller et là vous avez plein de marchands
qui vous
voilà améliorer votre arc améliorant de
vacances à améliorer votre votre armure
voilà voilà et il ya toujours des
petites quêtes aussi qu'ils vont se
débloquer alors que steph nous demande
si on peut kraft des acca alors je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse kraft et des
ak-47 sens car on est un peu dans un
anachronisme en à votre commentaire sur
twitter présidence 25 go nous dit pas ce
qu'il y à des films au japon mieux que
les sept samouraïs abbas à ce débat moi
je parie plus sur un ran de kurosawa
rossi qui est ca c est magnifique avec
des images de batailles vraiment
spectaculaire et qui est considéré comme
un classique tout autant que les sept
samouraïs donc voilà donc la samah
ajouté en discutant avec ce villageois
sam a ajouté une nouvelle mission voilà
qui vient d'apparaître ici pour me dire
murmure dans les bois voilà il y aurait
une forêt hantée
donc moi tous les coups c'est juste des
soldats mongols qui sont qui sont là
d'accord
oui parce qu on est on est pas dans un
bas pour voir pour vous resituer le
scénario c'est l'île de tsushima qui se
fait envahir par l'armée mongole qui dès
qu'il veut envahir mal la peau continuer
son expansion est au tout début du jeu
donc il ya tous les samouraïs de lille
qui décide par une centaine à une armée
c'est sa voix lasse et s'appuie sur tout
mais en face ils sont très très forts et
donc les samouraïs se font au aulas
olalalala un bug
elle va didon et pas madame c'est bon ça
ça devient rare ce genre de becerra
c'est le premier à 3 fois que j'en vois
donc comme ça bon bah vous voyez que le
jeu alors d'une certaine façon on vous
laisse avancer que ça ira mieux à n'ont
toujours pas toujours se désole jusque
là c'est bien jusque là tout allait bien
et donc oui bah les samouraïs se font
juste dégommer au début du jeu votre
votre oncle qui est un peu le big boss
de lille à lui les prisonniers ils ont
ils le tuent pas est donc là pour moment
notre objectif c'est de libérer votre
oncle donc lille l'oncle de jean sakai
que voilà et jean sakai lui aussi il a
été sacrément amoché au début du jeu et
heureusement une villageoise la soigner
et c'est elle qui lui apprend est la
voix on va dire la voix des voleurs et
la voix du déshonneur en tuant les gens
dans le dos d'accord donc là par exemple
voici un marchand un forgeron
voilà donc la milice bon bah t'as pas
assez de provisions déjà passées de fer
dont on ne peut pas améliorer ton katana
tant pis pour toi et donc quoi vous
pouvez voir que le jeu quand même est
extrêmement jolie avec toutes ces belles
feuilles qui avec son ambiance
complètement différent d'un clairement
clairement à lille est très diverse et
en plus je n'ai vu qu'une toute petite
partie de l'île encore mais bon là on
est dans une dans une très très belle
forêt tout tout doré mais si vous allez
on va un peu se téléporter voilà si on
va par ici par exemple
là on va être plutôt en bord de mer
alors l'avantagé aussi c'est que ça va
les chargements vont assez les tentes
donc c'est ça ça fait plaisir
et alors on a une question de
président benson qui nous demandent
comment sont les quêtes intéressante du
style witcher trois nuls genre aller
chercher trois rameaux de bambou alors
c'est pas oh c'est pas des cas de fedex
à la con c'est
non mais faut le dire va chercher des
fleurs va cueillir des fleurs on ramène
moi à 3 boulons pour réparer ma moto non
là il ya quand même c'est des quêtes
scénarisées
mais pas au point de the witcher
malheureusement ce genre de oui c'est
difficile d'arriver au niveau 2 de the
witcher est donc la voilà dans les
petites
dans les petites quêtes bon il ya
quelques unes qui sont sympas qui sont
rigolotes mais bon c'est pas non plus
des chefs-d'oeuvre d'écriture mais je
pense que les quêtes annexes sont plus
sympas que les que la quête principale
il faut pas hésiter à en faire sa bande
de gaza vous rapporte évidemment points
d'expérience et compagnie d'aviation
mais ça vous permet aussi d'explorer
beaucoup plus la carte de découvrir des
nouvelles choses un peu plus vous
imprégner de l'ambiance de l'île et est
donc voila mais après voilà c'est pas
non plus extrêmement bien écrit tout cas
on a quelques réactions à ce petit
problème de codage on salue au passage
miss cutie geisha qui nous a rejoint qui
est revenu on vous en remercie et
président benson qui nous dit en même
temps
sucker punch c'est sunset overdrive sur
xbox donc le codage trois petits points
c'est vrai que sucker punch se faisait
pas attendre sur des jeux d'aussi gros
gabarits on va dire là on attend
vraiment quand même une des grosses
sorties de l'année sucker punch je le
disais tout à l'heure alors vous l'avez
rappelé à juste titre c'est bien
évidemment 27 overdrive du concurrent ce
qui n'exclut d'ailleurs aussi mais de
l'autre côté c'est une autre exclu sur
playstation s'était in flames ou sly
cooper c'est donc des abbayes taille des
arbres iv mais pas forcément taillé des
jeux d'une dinde une si grosse attente
ouais bah il fait me saoul et paf en
fait
une fameuse saucisse et c'était du
pareil trip loi open world plutôt sympa
tosh mais pas non plus révolutionnaire
bombe à cette souche images je voulais
je voulais déjà dit et c'est à peu près
pareil il faut surtout pas aborder ce
jeu en se disant c'est la dernière
excuse sony donc ça va être énorme
estime ça va révolutionner médias jeux
vidéo non non non
non clairement pas mais c'est un jeu
sympa c'est un jeu sympa pour cet été
vous avez passé un trader un très bon
moment dessus ça va c'est pas non plus
révolutionnaire mais mais on s'ennuie
pas c'est bien maîtrisé ce mais par
contre c'est absolument pas original
vous allez retrouver énormément de
choses qui viennent d' assassin's creed
d'accord là
dans l'est les mécaniques de jeu enfin
vous voyez la carte a complété etc
il ya aussi the witcher parce qu'il ya
eu des phases enquête donc pareil va
falloir appuyé sur r2 pour regarder
japon des traces de parts oui je pense
qu'il ya eu une bagarre il se doit en
cas tant les pseudo enquête
donc ça c'est pas bon c'est pas non plus
très jeune et là je voulais vous le
montrer mais je vais aller à un autre un
autre sanctuaire ce que je ne peux pas
de grimper
voilà il ya des petites phrases gentilly
d'escaladé d'accord à huy up
donc je vais vous montrer vitier comment
ça se passe mais c'est pas très très
compliqué alors voir le voyez là je ne
peux pas passer donc il faut que je
trouve un autre lot tant qu'on s'y
rendent
je vois votre commentaire steph coiffure
en ondes et s'il est dispo sur switch
xbox sur ps4
ps5 alors 64 uniquement playstation 4
esquissera cross transportable sur la ps
5 au jeu ne serait pas surprise qu'il y
ait un qui y ait un portait de pc chaîne
cinq ans parce qu'on est déjà dans une
période de certains jeux on peut
précommander seront disponibles la fois
si on l'achète sur la ps4 et sur la peau
et ça c'est intéressant dans la lah
dessus on n'a pas encore de on n'a pas
encore de précisions sur gossau sophie
marceau si je me trompe mais voilà ce
sera pas surprenant il y aura très
certainement une version playstation 5
un peu plus joli
un peu plus rapide un peu plus mieux
mais bon comme il y avait eu déjà sur la
transition playstation 3 playstation 4
évidemment ce réseau la sauveuse deux
plus joli sur playstation 5 ça c'est
évident
donc va toutes les époques ce gta 5 qui
était sorti sur ps3 et qui était dispo
sur ps4
s'ils ont beaucoup jolie et qui est
toujours d'actualité ça c'est quand
j'étais à 5 assez incroyable oui et puis
il ya il y avait aussi eu la sauveuse
premier du nom qui avait été opéré
également sur playstation 4
pour ceux qui ne l'avaient pas fait
c'était mon cas et je l'avais vu le
parce que moi j'étais un joueur de huit
mois qu'ils soient sont 60 à l'époque et
j'avais migrer sur la ps4
alors je vois en tout cas clos et
beaucoup de demandes pour qu'on fasse du
stream commentaires d'albums notamment
donné que feu ou de nice caa
bah je suis désolé mais non on va faire
du commentaire de jeux vidéo on va
rester là dedans
mince on va pas pouvoir commenter d'une
expo du nice cache vraiment très déçu et
alors steve coiffure qu'ils nous
demandent figaro live comme le journal
le figaro oui tout à fait on fait du
stream cetef coiffure depuis environ
c'est loin d'être le premier prime jeu
vidéo que nous faisons ici au figaro
donc n'hésitez pas à nous retrouver
n'hésitez pas à nous suivre nous follow
sur sur twitch et on pourra vous en
proposer régulièrement mais tout à fait
aussi et bien de à l'actualité
n'hésitez pas à nous retrouver en stream
quasiment au quotidien pour découvrir
des contenus de l'actualité
on va y ait encore un très très beau
coucher de soleil regardez moi comme si
jolie avec quand même des colonnes de
fumée à gauche mais on sent qu'on est
dans un japon pas très pacifique acp
n'ont pas trop et en fait les colonnes
de fumée en fait il ya de bons quand
elles sont aussi grosse c'est j'avance
parce qu'il ya un an et demi ou une
ville qui s'est fait
baky c'est qu'ici ravagé mais quand
c'est des petits feux qu'on vous enjoins
généralement c'est des camps de réfugiés
d'accord ça beaucoup aussi david aller
les voir mais oui là ça sent ça sent ça
sent pas bon
voilà le feu ps de gros gros feu là bas
ont déjoué de gad howie ça va pas être
bien du tout on va s'en approcher
ailleurs toutes les pôles aussi mais bon
vous avez le choix entre trois chevaux
faire une question de
deux présidents benson qui nous
demandait je vais essayer de vous
reprendre comme ça on va pouvoir
rebondir là dessus elle classe comment
le cheval de relais dans le top des
chevaux jeux vidéo alors
il se classe plutôt pas mal c'est pas
c'est pas le premier le meilleur des
chevaux des jeux vidéo mais ils
répondent plutôt ils répondent plutôt
bien et contrairement par exemple à the
witcher 3 il bug pages arrachées pas
parfaitement son chemin j'avais su à
l'avancé
alors là nous arrivons sur un truc qui
peut faire de l'escaladé comme dans
skyrim non pas trop
donc non non on va pas l'emmener ce qui
a aidé par contre comme c'est un cheval
magique
bah vous pouvez partir escaladé dans
tous les sens vous le vous le sifflet
lors vous l'avez laissée à trois
kilomètres de là il anime en car il est
très très fort et donc vous avez le
choix entre trois chevaux donc moi j'ai
pris le gris nous en avait un noir vous
en avez un blanc et vous pouvez aussi
choisir son nom dont il ya 3 3 choix
différent donc le mien s'appelle no bout
mais on peut aussi l'appeler ceux-là et
le dernier je ne sais plus mais voilà
donc vous pouvez vous qui peut
personnaliser votre cheval est
évidemment il va l'appeler par son
prénom
il ya un lien sera à ces parties
reviendront donc moi je le weed c'est
aussi j'en ai pas parlé du doublage
donc comme vous entendez peut-être là le
jeu est en japonais car on peut vraiment
poussé l'immersion jusqu'au bout en
jouant avec les voix japonaises qui sont
extrêmement bien
donc n'hésitez pas à jouer en japonais
le doublage français est bof wolof ça
fait le taf mais c'est pas non plus
extraordinaire on n'est pas au niveau
d'un sweat-shirt par exemple dans une
oreille sur soi ou plus récemment d'un
effet de cette remake et les voix
anglaises pareil je suis pas très
convaincu donc je vois je vous conseille
plutôt de jouer en japonais le gros
défaut est temps que la synchronisation
labiale est fait sur l'anglais et non
pas sur le japonais a c'est quand même
paradoxal
voilà donc c'est bien bien dommage bon
là on va peut-être pour aller là-bas
j'ai pas envie de me battre et
et donc ça c'est un peu dommage donc sa
vague sur les cats in voilà on des fois
on voit un gros décalage entre le
mouvement des mouvements des lèvres
est ce que disent les personnes en
japonais donc voilà c'est un petit peu
un petit peu tristoune qu'ils aient pas
à pousser le trou jusqu'au bout et falla
synchro sur japonais comme ça tu joues
en japonais est à l'impression d'être
vraiment japon bah oui oui c'est que la
cclat bonjour à vous et merci de nous
rejoindre michel foltzer qui nous dit il
est bien le jeu c'est une réussite
merci de votre commentaire du genou vous
en êtes si si vous avez pu voir un petit
peu les limites de l'île et si vous avez
pu avancer
bonjour johnny mais rj illégalement sur
youtube n'est pas commentée à nous dire
si vous avez l'intention d'acheter le
jeu si vous souhaitez bien savoir
certaines choses on est là aussi pour
répondre à toutes vos questions
miss cutie gâcha qui me dit moi j'aime
trop le jeu il est trop bien merci
beaucoup de votre votre commentaire
voilà n'hésitez pas à commenter
il y avait aussi des questions en ce qui
concerne un remake sur pc notamment de
votre part mais ge qui nous demandait
s'il y aurait un remake
alors non on a bien évidemment
malheureusement c'est une exclu ps 4
donc pour les joueurs playstation
il va falloir faire un détour parce que
sur pc
horizon 0 zone sort sur pc donc là ça y
est on sent que sony lâche un peu du
lest et permet à certaines ses
exclusivités d'arriver sur pc mais
toujours avec quand même un certain
décalage ont peut-être que gossau
chinois sera porté sur pc dans d'ici
quelques mois mais pour le moment on n'a
pas d'information
mais voilà en tout cas pour pour vous
répondre mais je merci en tout cas de
vos questions et vos commentaires
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à ne dire
voilà ce que ce que vous en pensez
on a alors je sais pas si ça veut dire à
quelque chose un commentaire de guy mix
qui jean claude dubout noir gambetta
bonjour il ya parfois longtemps ça merci
à tous en tout cas d'être d'être avec
nous on est ensemble
encore encore un petit boom en un petit
moment pour pour essayer d'échanger là
sur ce sur ce ghost of tsushima qui est
donc sorti vendredi dernier avec et bien
ce commentaire voilà avec un jeu
efficace
j'aime bien aimé votre métaphore avance
live un bon jeu de l'été ah oui mais
pour moi c'est un très très bon jeu de
l'été en fête ce jeu vous voyez les
tbonds un été normal pas un été avec le
coronavirus il ya toujours des
blockbusters hollywoodiens qui sortent
au cinéma on sait que ça va pas être du
grand art ça va pas être genre un fil
des films à oscars ça va pas
révolutionner sa page voir ce film
incroyable ça peut être du gros
blockbusters qui tâche ça du jeu the
rock
voilà vous ça va être bas ça va être du
fast and furious ça va être du marvel
et ce genre de choses et bago cette
souche image un peu près pareil bref
c'est décidé c'est un gros blockbuster
qui fait plaisir on est content de le
voir on est contents d'y jouer on passe
un très bon moment dessus et à
l'intérieur de l'appareil de renard
pardon on passe un très bon moment
dessus probablement du ciment on l'aura
oublié mais sur le moment c'est un
moment plutôt phone est on est on n'est
pas mécontent d'avoir dépensé lé 50,60
euros que va le jeu comme on n'est pas
forcément mécontent d'avoir mis 10 euros
dans le dernier apple voilà même si
c'est pas non plus grands films ben
voilà c'est pareil qu'aux shima ce n'est
pas un grand grand jeu mais un bon jeu
pour s'occuper cet été entendu ben je
pense que c'est une septième bombe
retour sur sur ce jeu est ce que en ce
qui concerne l'univers
on va dire historique est du japon il ya
des certains jeux qui vous ont marqué
que vous avez envie d'aborder donc des
jeux qui se passe au japon alors moi je
vais pas répondre sur les jeux qui se
passe dans le japon médiéval et c'est
moi un jeu qui se passe au japon que
j'adore ça s'appelle personnes à 5
oui alors oui il a bien d'autres se
passe dans le japon moderne japon
d'aujourd'hui voilà dans ça pour le coup
c'est une grosse grosse licence le
personne qui est devenu une grosse
licence que c'était une licence vraiment
de niche auparavant et donc voilà
persona pour vous grosso modo c'est des
jeux de l'ue qui se passe au lycée avec
des lycéens qui ont des sortes de super
pouvoirs et qui vont s'en servir pour
combattre des missions et personne à 5
se passe aujourd'hui à tokyo
et voilà quand on connaît on connaît un
petit peu la ville c'est super super
chouette ça c'est une très belle
reproduction de la ville une très belle
reproduction de ce que c'est qu'être
lycéen au japon et voilà si vous voulez
voir une autre facette plus moderne de
ce pays je vous conseille grandement
personnes à 5 mai d'autant que le jeu
est ressorti récemment sur playstation 4
traduit en français ce qui n'était pas
le cas de la première version tout était
en anglais et c'est pas mal parce que le
jeu dur comme une centaine d'heures il
est extrêmement bavard il ya énormément
de textes sabres avant tout donc donc ça
que sa pub ça a pu perdre pas mal de
monde
et ben on attend rien je vais quand même
faire un combat alors pas tout à fait
dans le même style mais qui reste
asiatiques
yakuza en chine 2 pour tf1 ballon il ya
causé chez nous qui en chine je pourrais
confondez comme on l'appelle le
président benson mais voilà je lisais
votre commentaire sans réfléchir
oui bien sûr il ya plus à gagner le red
bull par contre qu'il va faire son grand
retour il y à quelques quelques années à
le 3 avant de sortir pour de vrai oui et
c'était pas c'était pas sortir ou
laisser faire mais en tout cas
ouais mais beaucoup de jeu et n'hésitez
pas à nous dire
à nous dire ce que vous en pensez si
vous avez des coups de coeur qui se
passe au japon ou en asie c'est toujours
intéressant alors il ya en effet pas la
période actuelle avec yakuza qui se
passe là aussi dans une ville pas
forcément trop réaliste mais avec un
autre type de jeu moi j'avais choisi de
vous en parler aussi un petit peu parce
qu'on est on a de la chance en tout cas
en ce qui concerne le japon médiéval ou
un peu plus récents donc on en a parlé
tout à l'heure avec ses croquis qu'il
aborde une vision un peu moins réaliste
entre guillemets pareil de l'univers du
jeu réalise des combats beaucoup plus du
des combats on avait ni eau également
qui se rapprocher aussi un peu plus d'un
dead souls et moi ce que je vous
conseille avec grand plaisir et j'espère
que vous êtes connaisseur de ce jeu
c'est shogun total war 2 il y avait 9 1
qui était bien mais alors le 2 est
excellent là c'est un jeu de simulation
bataille qui est vraiment excellent où
on gère l'ensemble du japon et on doit
gérer les différentes différence entre
seigneurs mais également avec les
imbrications extérieur au japon et avec
des réalisations de bataille qui sont
extrêmement réaliste je vous conseille
en tout cas ce gros coup de coeur moi
que j'ai shogun total war 2 et après de
façon un peu plus ancienne et ballet
tenchu tenchu qui était sorti sur ps1 à
l'époque qui étaient là un jeu de ninja
un jeu d'infiltration qui de ce qu'on a
pu voir était déjà un peu plus réaliste
sur l'infiltration de la ps1 on devait
gérer certaines armes avec des lames en
un petit peu empoisonné des grappins on
devait marcher sur les toits sauter au
dessus des ennemis et le but du jeu
c'était non pas de les tuer forcément
mais plutôt de les esquiver à super
alors là
vous voyez un petit oiseau jaune qui me
qui me guide en fait il apparaît de
temps en temps pour vous guider vers un
endroit sympa donc là une source chaude
donc en fait ça permet de s'accroître un
petit peu sa barre de santé
d'accord et hop là
couples a même rapport à la nudité que
dans votre vie de chat ouais le bain
trois ans pas là donc on peut être
petite réflexion secours temps et dans
le bain à bord ce jour à plein de choses
mais la paix intérieure c'est parti
voilà arrête de réfléchir
d'accord et vous allez voir ma barbe de
santé 20 tout petit peu augmenté
mais bon on vous laisse vous un briquet
de ce moment de réflexion et de
méditation
mesdames profiter en tout cas merci à
vous gros dur vous avez très bon goût
total war shogun 2 au japon médiéval mon
total war préféré bas je suis d'accord
moi même si c'est plutôt empailleur
puisque j'aime beaucoup l'histoire
notamment américaines au moment de la
colonisation mais je sois good total war
qui se vaut tout à fait et qui est très
intéressant et qui donc est vraiment un
petit coup de coeur n'hésitez pas si
d'ailleurs vous avez aussi des
références cinématographiques à nous les
volets m c'est toujours agréable aussi
de pouvoir échanger sur tout ce que hors
jeu vidéo une oeuvre culturelle que nous
le rappeler en ce qui concerne toutes
les oeuvres musicales à défaut de nice
cas et et de bnl qu'on a pu entendre
tout à l'heure dans le chat mais
également bah voilà tout ce qui va être
ce qui va être cinéma et jeu vidéo
alors là vous avez peut-être vu je suis
un vieux routier renard et qui lui va
m'amener sur un sur un sanctuaire et
plus je débloque de sanctuaires plus ça
va me permettre d'équiper des petites
amulettes qui vont voilà hop là un
emplacement de charme
alors non charme ça me rend pas plus
sexy le charme
voilà je vais vous montrer c'est des
petites âmes il est que vous allez
gagner au fur et à mesure du jeu
la panne un nouveau donc charme de
férocité augmentation modérée des dégâts
au corps à corps leurs patients de
destruction deux fois plus de dégâts
charme de l'ong vitesse de détection des
ennemis de plus 10%
donc voila en gros vous pouvez vous
rajoutez des petits avantages donc vous
alors qu'est ce que je vais me mettre
xiam de bien-être récente et restauré
par les soins post 7 25% si ça doit être
des sels de bain 7,5 pour cent c'est
très précis
eh bien écoutez à plat charme de
férocité augmentation des dégâts de
corps à corps donc j'ai déjà voilà un
jeu affiche plus de dégâts moi j'ai de
santé plus j'veux plus je tape fort
voilà quand j'ai mis des ennemis ça me
restera un petit peu ma santé oui je
très axé santé les ennemis arrêtent vous
cherchez 40 % plus vite et donc vous
pouvez un peu vous composez votre bijou
comme comme vous le souhaitez et dans
l'équipement aussi alors dans les tenues
donc on a parlé des différentes d'armure
qu'on peut mettre mais il ya aussi des
choses totalement inutile quand ça ne
sert à rien juste à faire joli don
pouvait mettre un très beau casque de
clan de samouraï 1 qu'est ce que raffiné
extrêmement discret un chapeau de paille
quatre anneaux sur ce live voilà donc
voilà comme ça vous ne voyez rien un
petit bandeau voilà différents bandeau
que vous allez aussi gagné trouver un
peu partout dans le monde
allez je vais mettre un petit casque de
samouraï et vous pouvez aussi mettre des
masques un pareil ça ne sert à rien sauf
à faire mais c'est beau gosse voilà donc
hop je vais mettre celui là donc je vais
j'ai ma petite
il ya quand même un côté
personnalisation qui est plutôt sympa
mais qui est plutôt sympa on peut parce
que là aussi je peux vous montrer sur
les tenues
on peut débloquer aussi des couleurs
pour ça pour son armée aux dons qu'il ya
différentes couleurs seront pas les
gagner automatiquement soit on va les
acheter
donc c'est totalement esthétique c'est
juste pour le plaisir des yeux ça ne
change rien vos statistiques et et oui
on ne peut qu'aller c'est un renard oh
lalala lalala
et voilà deux points de plus pour le jeu
aaa
ouf allez on attend petit renard va
vivre sa vie
mais d'accord je alors qu'on voit une
bâtisse au loin et alors que fleur de
fraises sur youtube tombe des nues un
média de droite qui joue un jeu vidéo à
la mais si vous saviez ça fait des
années si vous aviez ça fait longtemps
qu'on string du jeu vidéo sur figaro
live ça fait pas longtemps qu'on stream
sur youtube mais n'hésitez pas à nous
suivre on est tout le temps là on est
pendant que vous nous regardez fleurs de
fraises on est en ce moment même sur
twitch ou là on a des gens qui nous
suivent un peu plus et sur la page
principale du figurant mais également
sur facebook donc n'hésitez pas à nous
retrouver puisque bas que ce soit pour
de l'actualité ou pour et bien du jeu
vidéo on est toujours là et oui on peut
on peut faire ce qu'on fait et faire du
jeu vidéo il s'est en rien un problème
vous le voyez au contraire on vous donne
rendez vous voyagez en profitent ainsi
il ya pas mal d'articles sur le sur le
jeu vidéo sur le site du figaro vous
pouvez les chercher notamment dans la
rubrique tech
il y en a plein dans la rubrique médias
aussi en a pas mal et voilà sur
ce qui se passe chez nintendo sur ce qui
se passe chez sony ce qui se passe chez
microsoft on a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'articles sur le jeu donc
n'hésitez pas allez n'hésitez pas à les
consulter on va peut-être pas forcément
faire déserter pour dire voilà les
dernières sorties mais plutôt sur le
volet un peu business on peut économiser
sur mais voilà on a parlé beaucoup
d'animal crossing ces derniers mois
également
on n'était pas les seuls on souhaitait
pas les ailes on a parlé d' animal
crossing quand on a plein de choses donc
voilà ne pensait pas parce que ces
figures on ne parle pas de jeux vidéo si
si si on en parle beaucoup de la reprise
et de l'année alors que on salue mais
que merican great guen qui nous demande
si on peut chasser les renards un fait
non on peut maintenant non non non non
on voit par ils sont très mignons dans
wind on sait seulement les abats alors
ça par contre c'est moins mignon va vous
voyez là vu que c'est la guerre il ya
des gens qui se sont fait prendre
alors que mike american great games nous
demande quand on sort le jeu est bien ce
jeu est déjà sorti vous pouvez le
retrouver en démat ou en maths et il est
sorti vendredi dernier et on remercie en
tout cas eric delos pour votre gentil
message et qui trouve le jeu très beau
ce un effet une des grandes qualités de
ce jeu peut-être la principale c'est la
beauté et surtout le mode photo qui du
coup va vous permettre là je vois qu'un
ours s'est glissée dans le camp c'est ça
non fois j'ai peut-être rêver non ah non
non ça c'est une trêve à mon dieu oh mon
dieu en fait j'ai fait une bêtise j'ai
des bêtises j'ai fait betty
pas de finale et j'ai pas j'ai pas bien
observé le camp en fait il est beaucoup
trop grand et je vous avoue qu'on lie à
gérer les combats de la vague gentiment
partir mais oui en fait alors ça aussi
c'est un côté far cry
il ya certains camps mongolie l'ondé ils
ont des ours qui sont en prison pas
gourmand piquage si vous êtes vilain
vous pouvez vous dire vrai mais ça m'est
aussi arrivé de me dire ah ah j'avais
les ouvrir sauf qu'en fait lorsqu'il m'a
donné beaucoup de passes et je suis
morte voilà donc fait c'est pas très
beau chinois en tout cas cette sortie de
combat non alors je sais que mon honneur
on prend un coup mais voilà les et moi
mais je n'assumerai pas de faire d'avoir
un autre game over donc alors que
michael merican great games nous demande
si le jeu sortira sur pc xbox which
mobile alors non il ne sort que sur ps4
pour le moment peut-être argenté
quelqu'un sur le live dire qu'il y avait
des nouvelles sur une version pc donc si
vous avez des infos
oui alors ce que c'était maillage tout à
l'heure qu'il nous disait qu'il y avait
pas forcément de nouvelles justement et
que pour mon nom n'y avait pas trop de
vous faut pas désespérer en vue qu'il ya
certainement dans certaines des
faillites et sony qui arrive sur pc donc
voilà les pc liste rassurez-vous
peut-être que ça va arriver
et merci en tout cas votre commentaire
sicaud grid zaiko great qu'on salue et
qu'on remercie qui nous dicte le jeu est
bel et bien sorti le 17 juillet oui tout
à fait mais kim ngân great games qui a
une demande si on peut exploser les ours
avec du c4 voilà aussi ce sera un peu
anachronique
ouais on va pas pouvoir utiliser deux c4
j'en suis navré et alors là c'est c'est
le mode un petit peu super que ouais en
fait c'est le mode confrontation
d'accord est en fait quand vous repérer
des ennemis vous pouvez décider ben
voila vous l'avouer vraiment bushido et
donc de lait de dire venez vous battre
et non pas ils viennent se battre et ça
vous permet d'en dégommer jusqu'à quatre
à la suite très très facile ça c'est
chouette
c'est vrai que je l'aï regardée en tout
cas dans les styles de combat ça me
rappelle aussi un peu l'ombre du mordor
qui a inclus dans ce style avec
notamment un open world
des explorations et des combats un peu
dans ce style car c'est dommage je n'ai
plus de coups night se sont vraiment
très s'éteint un accessoire extrêmement
pratique parce que ça vous permet
d'envoyer des coups d'oeil dans cette
sorte de petit de petits couteaux sur
l'ennemi et ça les fait les déstabilise
qui bien que il ya que le sabre alors
oui il ya que le sabre et après il ya
aussi des accessoires l'or par contre je
ne sais pas si j'y vois là vous voyez là
je suis sur un un ennemi avec boucliers
donc j'ai changé de posture
voilà donc ce qui permet de sortir le
combo qui permet de passer en gros en
dessous des boucliers de la part de nos
armées oui donc la posture engagée sur
de la posture pour les boucliers et si
je tente de changer de posture sur
l'épée voyez que je me tiens
différemment et il ya quatre posture au
total à a déclenché enfin à débloquer le
jeu est difficile si on s'y met et qu'on
a envie de le terminer ce qu'il ya des
séquences rachat reconnaît alors est-ce
que c'est difficile globalement non mais
il ya certaines missions qui sont quand
même un petit peu complexe
que vous allez devoir refaire plusieurs
fois parce que parce que des fois les
ennemis vous d'été vous comprenez pas
trop comment parce que des fois il
arrive à 150 sur vous comprenez pas trop
comment non plus mais bon ça reste quand
même je fais à sylvain quand vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est passé qui n'ont
plus à l'est mais après c'est pas non
plus extrêmement agressif si vous avez
si vous n'avez pas l'habitude des jeux
d'action c'est pas non plus le meilleur
jeu par lequel par lequel commencer
parce qu'il faut quand même comme vous
avez vu les combats reste un petit peu
légère dose de technique et de stratégie
il faut quand même savoir esquivé faut
savoir paraît faut savoir changer de
position enfin changer de posture faut
s'adapter à son adversaire donc c'est
pas voilà faut pas non plus faire
tap tap tap tap tap en disant ça va
passer non ça marche ça marche pas comme
ça
même si voilà ça nous coûterait très
compliqué si vous avez l'habitude de ce
type de cheveux alors que on à une
question sur youtube on nous demande si
on peut adopter un nouveau cheval alors
le cheval vous pouvez le choisir ce que
l'on nous a expliqué en début de soleil
on peut choisir en début de jeu et après
en fait j'ai vu que dans certains
endroits bon il ya des chevaux
un peu comme dans red dead en fait vous
pouvez d emprunter mais quand vous allez
sifflet votre cheval c'est le cheval de
sud rail qui va qui va venir
donc c'est lui pour moi c'est lui qui
viendra à chaque fois mais après je peux
toujours partie avec le cheval de
quelqu'un d'autre
si jamais j'en ai besoin j'ai besoin
urgemment d'un
d'un cheval mais après lui il répond au
doigt et à l'oeil enflé tout de suite
[Musique]
j'essaie de vous montrer un petit coin
de l'île house pourrait relayer
allez on va partir par là
n'hésitez pas en tout cas nous dire si
vous l'avez fait si vous avez joué à la
ghost of toshima et des anneaux dire où
vous en êtes et ce que vous en avez
pensé vous avez le droit d'être déçu par
ce jeu aussi
alors on a cette question sur youtube il
ya est ce qu'il ya des rumeurs
concernant un remake j'imagine que vous
parlez d'un gros sportage peut-être sur
la ps cinq coups sûrs sur pc bas pour le
moment nous on a peu d'informations
là-dessus mais pour le moment non mais
très très probable dans ce serait très
long serait sur poignant qui n'est pas
une version playstation 5 2 face aux
chinois qu'ils sortent d'ici un an
comme toutes les exclues les récents des
exclus sony à avoir leur version toute
jolie n'y lycée pour pour la playstation
5 et donc ouais pour ceux qui nous qui
nous rejoignent je vais vous montrer
aussi dans cette mécanique de gameplay
comme vous voyez il n'y a pas de carte
qui s'affiche à l'écran pour dire c'est
cette direction qu'il faut suivre
regarde le gps je vais te guider ouais
en fait là c'est le vent qui va vous
donner l'indication parce que là
l'orientation à suivre donc ça va être
il faut aller plutôt vers le sud vers le
nord ouest ça va pas être vraiment là
direction vraiment précise alors il faut
tourner à droite ou troisième
au troisième homme publié sur la gauche
n'ont l'air fou quand même vous
débrouiller pour passer les pour passer
les obstacles mais je trouve que c'est
vraiment une hall alors regardez comme
c'est beau c'est vraiment une excellente
idée pour voilà vous déjà vous faire
profiter des décors autour de vous de
vous repérer tout seul aussi de garder
en mémoire certains endroits jara oui
c'est vrai il faut passer par là pour la
dentelle ferme
je trouve ça beaucoup plus efficace
parce que moi je sais pas vous mais par
exemple dans un gta
si on me coupe le gps je suis incapable
de retrouver mon chemin
moi j'aime bien sûr les reds est là par
exemple
je me forçais à pas mettre les
guidage gps pour essayer de repérer le
jeu alors par contre c'est beaucoup plus
long il faut s'accrocher mais de temps
en temps ça fait du bien ouais mais toi
par exemple dans gta tu as quand même
plein de chemin que tu reprends tout le
temps pour amener à la base
et ben si on me retire elle ne sait plus
par où passait à je crois que c'est là
bas mais je suis pas certaine et c'est
bien sûr c'est quelque chose que je
trouve très dommage dans les os payant
parce qu'on a tellement faim on passe
son temps dedans mais en fait on est
complètement perdue si on n'a pas à son
appât l'autoguidage alors que la dengue
aux sushis me voyez c'est quand même
chouette de profiter de l'écran joffin
là vous voyez n'y a rien il n'y a
strictement rien et c'est c'est quand
même très très rare un open world bien
sûr a dit milo d'indication sur l'écran
entre la mini map et je te rappelle les
commandes et je te rappelle qu'elle
capte en train de suivre
et puis je te mets des jauges dans tous
les sens
là bas on a sept on a fait ce
commentaire d'eric des lots sur facebook
qui nous dit c'est original cette façon
de se repérer c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment très beau non c'est vraiment
faire fermer une excellente idée
enfin je pense que c'est vraiment
l'originalité du jeu ans et c'est la
direction par le vent et j'ose espérer
que d'autres d'autres studios devront
s'en inspirer parce que dans ce type de
déplacement il y avait aussi bien celle
d'à breath of the wild qui lui ne
l'avait pas la mécanique du vent mais
plutôt la mécanique de au regarde autour
de soi on voit au moins quatre ou cinq
choses différentes à voir l explorer on
rajoute ça sur sa petite carte juste en
appuyant sur un bouton et c'est parti et
c'était pareil un jeu ou pas il faut
ouvrir les yeux et bien là c'est pareil
c'est un jeu on ouvre les yeux tout le
temps mais également où il faut utiliser
un scanner et dire ok donc là il ya tel
deposit de trucs et on va aller dans
cette direction a par exemple à scarce à
cet endroit là j'y suis allé il ya pas
longtemps
ouais j'arriverai au dessus voilà
bonjour monsieur j'arrive au dessus de
ma montagne et la joie ait un petit
chemin allant voir ce qui s'y trouve est
rien à voir je suis si si si si il ya
quelques jours voyez up là-haut des pnj
donc à une toute petite quête qui va
c'est vraiment du lot même pas qui va
tuer tes conneries que je me suis dit
tiens prenons ce petit chemin escarpé
alors qu absolument rien me disait sont
ma carte va dire il faut aller là bas
parce qu'il va se passer quelque chose
d'accord et le jeu est rempli de ce
genre de petites interactions donc là
elle me dit oh j'ai trouvé un moyen de
telli le regarder en regardant bien on
est allé voir mon bateau hop je me place
là où il faut
j'observe
je ne vois rien dans mes seins il n'y a
rien
et puis tu te retournes c'est en fait tu
le fais pour sa petite rose on est là à
à la vilaine elle est là tuez-le à la
villageoise c'est une traîtresse et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aux traîtres aux
chinoises
a aussi un des défauts du jeu c'est la
gestion de la caméra qui est juste
oui j'en ai entendu parler
alors qu'on a une question intéressante
je suis en train de me renseigner mais
peut-être que vous pourrez vous aider
chloé sur la durée de vie du jeu
approximativement pour un genre moyens
alors bon j'ai pas fini le jeu mais de
ce que j'ai lu ça fait d'entre encore 20
30 tonnes ce qui est ce qui est mon
vieil homme moyen ce que papa peu ce qui
n'est pas non plus à plat ça dépend
comme d'habitude comment vous jouez soit
vous allez en ligne droite et vous allez
faire les quêtes principales et quelques
petites quêtes secondaires à droite à
gauche soit vous allez vouloir être
complice sioniste est vraiment nettoyés
toute la map et là vous pouvez vous
rajouter au moins de dix 10 ou 15 heures
de plus facilement si vous voulez
absolument tout faire et en fait c'est
marrant parce que je me rends compte l'a
enjointe cette petite 4
parce que donc pour tout vous dire en
fête ou partie de ma sauvegarde a
disparu juste avant ce avant ce live
donc là je suis quelques heures en
arrière avant là où je suis censé en
être
et c'est là que je vais en faire la
différence de difficulté que en fait
j'étais devenu bien plus fort dans
madame la dernière build parce que là
normalement cette super 7 benji aux
normands en deux secondes je là je la
hais trucidant de coûts et la banque m'a
fallu un peu plus de temps pour venir à
bout d'accord donc il ya vraiment quand
même une progression de son personnage
parce qu'au tout début du jeu il paraît
tellement fort aussi mais en fait
comment est-ce qu'il va comment est-ce
qu'il va évoluer et bon en fait là je me
rends compte que quand même les niveaux
les ennemis ont des niveaux même si
c'est pas indiqué non c'est pas
impliqués ils sont dix sept niveaux 24
mais voilà il ya quand même une
progression qui se voit voilà au niveau
des techniques notamment donc vous avez
c'est pour les esquives
la danse du coup au effective et trois
attaques impossible à bloquer
consécutifs infusions de plantes etc
vous avez plein de petits
de nouveaux mouvements qui vont se
débloquer de nouvelles choses qui vont
un peu enrichir le gameplay dont le coût
des pôles pour charger les ennemis
la frap décalé pareil enfin vous allez
pouvoir un peu améliorée de ce que peut
faire votre personnage donc les postures
comme en ont déjà parlé
les fantômes voilà c'est sûr donc là
j'ai le coup d'oeil
la bombe de poudre noire
la bombe collante le carillon qui ne
sert à rien jeter j'avais des on
souhaite petite cloche mais qui attire
l'attention de l'ennemi dans
l'infiltration je verrai ça fait du
bruit donc ces fameux je balance une
pierre ouais mais sauf qu'en fait la la
portée du son est très limité et bon
achat que j'ai essayé en fait les gardes
ne l'entendez pas ce que c'était c'était
pas assez proche d'eux et la bombe la
bombe films viennent donc là voilà je
veux vous voyez en haut à droite en fait
j'ai un point à dépenser d'accord dans
je n'ai pas encore fait donc part énoncé
vous faites des missions plus à l'est
c'est plus allez avoir des points
dépensés dans les capacités de votre
façon tu en as un commentaire
intéressant de grues du qui nous demande
sur youtube afin qu'il nous dit plus tôt
dans beaucoup de jeu en monde ouvert on
a une sorte de brouillard au loin qui
complique le repérage sans gps la saq la
désormais de plus en plus sur les jeux
vidéo la capacité de visibilité la
d'apparitions et de moins en moins
restreinte et permet aussi à la fois en
plus d'être belle de se repérer plus
facilement et une immersion beaucoup
plus forte
oui oui bah là non non il n'y a pas du
tout des faits brouillard là on peut là
c'est juste en fait il ya ya ya juste un
blocage on va lire le scénario
hop voyez en fait l'île de sushis mal et
super grande mais pour le moment je n'ai
accès qu'à la partie fut donc il faut
que je termine un certain nombre de
quêtes quête principale pour pouvoir
débloquer ce ne l'a donc le château de
kaneda qui m'empêche de passer sur
l'autre parent d'accord on a une
question de make-up merican great games
qui nous demandent combien de giga le
jeu fait tilt
est ce qu'il est ou beaucoup beaucoup ce
qu'en plus j'ai dû le télécharger à aa
alors sans payer en plus oui ça prend un
peu de temps information non ohlala
allez les informations voilà 50 gigas
c'est un service à la sagesse de ses
deux fois oui et puis pareil un red dead
redemption va être un peu plus lourd je
pense oui oued pareil c'était une
centaines de giga donc la wii 50 gigas
ça va on va dire c'est un jeu de cette
qualité quand même graphique c'est
plutôt plutôt positif et alors que make
american greetings nous demande si on va
faire des l'année du fortnight alors non
ce n'est pas prévu
déjà parce que je suis un piètre joueur
de fortes knight et notamment parce que
ben non des lan
par contre on aimerait bien avec juin
qu'une aile kivu réalise cela est fait
qu'on remercie d'ailleurs pouvoir
couvrir de temps en temps certaines
assez connue donc rester connecté si on
y arrive on vous le fera alors ça va il
va falloir être un peu patient parce que
ça c'était des plans avant crise
sanitaire
mais si les choses reprennent dans
l'ordre pourquoi pas ça ne sera pas
impossible de suivre des lan en direct
sur figaro live ce serait une belle
première bon bah je pense qu'on a on a
fait un beau tour chloé alors que vous
êtes repéré par avait pas vu donc c'est
le seul truc qui ment quand on est
habitué de faire bref à the breath away
the wild side à la norme ans j'ai envie
de sortir mon parapente
ah oui
niveaux bas non pas par un jour je vous
déconseille de le faire ceci non ça va
falloir appeler le cheval magique et
descendre et ouais non là on peut
malheureusement on ne peut pas faire ça
donc ça c'est de la petite fantaisie qui
manque un peu quand on est on est tout
en haut on peut pas prendre son delta
plane hélas hélas à ce qu'en fait il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se débloquent en
hauteur vous voyez là-bas tout là haut
voilà il ya quelque chose tu rates
ernement un camp ennemi réflexe qu'on
avait qu'on pouvait avoir de temps en
temps dans far cry aussi on va les
trouver 2 3 de la place saint-paul
wingsuit dans le far cry 3 way en plus
rire il ya donc là non on peut pas non
là le seul truc hein pour enfin henri
goût c'est dans les capacités à
débloquer on peut en faire une
on peut débloquer une qui permet à la
fin d'assaut de faire une roulade ce qui
permet de réduire les dégâts avant ne
pas prendre dit d'accord on est loin du
deltaplane
ouais on est aujourd'hui dans cette
année je pense pas que ça marche ça fait
un saut de 500 mètres de hauteur je
pense pas que ça marche je pense mais je
pense pas non plus bon bah on va arriver
en tout cas la fin de ce stream ou voilà
on a pu vous faire découvrir grosse teuf
tsushima moi c'était une grosse
découverte puisque je vois là je m'étais
pas trop spoiler le jeu et je suis
content d'avoir pu découvrir avec vous
on à votre question lomig vous nous
demandez si on a fait le test
de l'asfls ii alors malheureusement non
selon la rater ça aurait été un grand
plaisir mais christiane iter oblige ce
n'est pas forcément facile de vous
organiser des tests comme ça mais bon on
essaiera d'être plus régulier en même
temps que les choses iront un peu mieux
voilà donc on vous donne rendez vous
tout au long de l'année pour la fois des
stream jeu vidéo mais aussi et ça c'est
au quotidien des stream actualité
parfois des stream sur le terrain
d'ailleurs vendredi je serai sur le
terrain au sein de la protection de
l'enfance pour vous faire découvrir la
façon dont les enfants en situation de
fragilité va vivre cette crise sanitaire
vous voyez qu'on peut aussi découvrir
des choses un peu multiples et variées
en stream sur ce même format
je vais vous remercie avant qu'on se
quitte l'omi bien sur youtube avec
american great guen eric delos sur
facebook gros du sur youtube on a un
internaute alors je pense pas que ce
soit son nom alors sinon c'était
vraiment un nom qui tombe qui tombe de
la providence chloé thibault sur youtube
ben merci en tout cas d'avoir changé
votre nom pour nous on espère vous
inspiré autant que l'on aime pouvoir
faire des stream avec vous on va
remercier stream steph coiffure
président benson sur twitch bah voila
merci à tous on avait également guy mx 0
bah voilà en tout cas je vous remercie a
tous moi je vous donne rendez vous au
quotidien sur figaro live que ce soit
sur la page principale du figaro sur
facebook sur twitter est maintenant sur
youtube on est régulièrement là donc
n'hésitez pas à nous retrouver
régulièrement l'occasion pour moi
également de vous remercier chlorés pour
se
très beau test très intéressant on vous
retrouve dans les pages va tech du
figaro pour des actus jeu vidéo mais pas
que oui mais pas que non non sur va tout
l'actu tech
voilà c'est sur le figaro économie voilà
n'hésitez pas à retrouver tous les
articles de chloé et moi je vous dis à
très bientôt sur vos gars au live au
symbole ivz
robitaille à tombouctou masta soliloque
kruger gaudreau pollender hitachi mister
no made you et aider nos mémoires
mais bon